[Music]
even though Victoria's got cancelled
after three seasons it's still hard to
believe the series ended the show's
skyrocketed ariana grande to stardom and
became one of the most popular shows on
nickelodeon at the time but have you
ever noticed just how many innuendos it
has there's even an episode where the
characters have an obsession with fees
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
and give this video a big thumbs up if
you still watch victorious now let's
check out ten funny little jokes and
victorious you might have missed
adolescent joke Nickelodeon is known to
never really hold back when it comes to
teenage jokes that will probably go over
a teenager's head but if Yuri watched
some of these as an adult you might
appreciate some of these jokes a lot
better in the first episode of season 3
also known as the holiday special
episode Andre got upset for receiving
his first failing grade ever he gets
angry and asks how it's possible for a
person to go from an a to a deep Jade
whose minds seemed to be far away from
grades it replies by saying that this
happened to her in the 8th grade did you
catch the joke while Andre is definitely
talking about failing the class Jade is
actually talking about puberty and her
going from an a-cup to a detail if you
watched this as a kid you probably just
thought she was talking about failing
grades in the eighth grade but it turns
out Jade's joke is much heavier with an
innuendo only older people would
understand and in earlier take of the
same classroom scene we see Andre losing
his cool and pushing Robbie off the
chair we then hear Jade's hilarious
comment that she vets that jingled
Robbie's Belle's any windows never end
when you're on the Nickelodeon show and
we have all these funny jokes to prove
it
hey guys please check out the most
awesome sisters on YouTube sister fun
watch can play the latest games go on
amazing adventures and just doing all
sorts of fun and silly things if you
have kids
little brothers or sisters or if you
just want to join in on a family fun you
subscribe to their Channel
that's not my head you have to admit
that Nickelodeon sometimes takes it just
a little bit too far with their adult
jokes we totally understand putting a
few innuendos in the script here and
there but almost every episode in
Victorious has a joke that kids will
never understand let's go back to the
pilot where we slowly get to know Tori
Vega and the rest of the Hollywood Arts
High School gang when it comes to the
talent show scene we see a teacher
telling a student to put the microphone
on Tori's head but we then hear Tori
complaining that the person didn't put
the microphone on her head and hinting
they put it somewhere else we'd like to
keep our channel kid-friendly so we
won't tell you where Nickelodeon thinks
the microphone actually was but you can
probably get the idea the joke was
innocent enough to go over kids heads
but we bet watching it back will make
you go ill in the pilot we also start
getting to know the personalities of the
show's main characters but have you
noticed that Jade's voice and her look
has actually changed since the very
first episode pay attention to the scene
where the students have to improv you'll
see that Jade's character and her strong
personality developed more as the show
went on I'm a throat player if you're
still with us let us know by writing
teen victorious in the comments section
in the third episode of season one we
get to learn more about Tori's talents
Tori is becoming more and more
frustrated that she has to carry around
and play a horn when she'd much rather
sing in UserVoice simple writes we all
have different talents and it's
important to try things out when you're
a kid so an Andre and Kat find Tori
being all frustrated she admits that
she's not an instrument player in her
words she says that her throat is her
instrument and she's a throat player
instead Andre says that it doesn't count
and Kat adds that it sounds kind of
gross
you wouldn't think much of this joke as
a child but I'm sure there are many
adults out there who know why throat
playing just isn't something that should
ever be said in a show like victorious
being a throat player definitely sounds
gross and way too inappropriate for a
kids TV show we're telling you
Nickelodeon has absolutely no filter
even though it would definitely be
useful to turn on at least once in a
while let's just hope being a thorough
player doesn't put a lot of pressure on
your throats do you have a credit card
this is probably one of the most
innocent jokes on the show but
but there are a lot of adults who have
experienced real life people that behave
this way kids love to ask for money
right for the seventh episode of season
one featured a scene with cat and Sinden
and it feels like an introduction to
Kanye West's gold-digger song cat is
excited over the sky store catalog she
got on an airplane he becomes completely
obsessed and buys tons of ridiculous
stuff until back ends up ripping the
catalogue to stop her toward the end of
the episode cat then notices Sinjin and
innocently asks him if he has a
girlfriend Cindy says no and then cat
asks if he has a credit card to which he
replies with I guess cat then suddenly
becomes totally interested in him and
ends up seductively stroking his arm and
telling them to call her sometime how
does Kanye West's song go again we can
definitely find those lyrics in cat's
behavior we just hope this was just an
inappropriate joke and cat didn't really
do anything with Sinjin just so she
could get money from him we all know
ariana grande loves to sing about
embracing the sensual side of being a
woman but we do hope that nickelodeon
knows these characters are too young to
do any love related favors to their
friends in exchange for money Jen Jen
versus Dade teenagers are reckless
especially when we like someone the
Victoria's had a scene that made Sinjin
look well just a little bit creepy
remember the ninth episode of the first
season called the Wi-Fi in the sky Tori
starts to video chat with Andre cat and
Beck to get started on the group
assignment they have to do after a while
simian appears and this has been things
get a bit weird as jade realizes that
the lamp and the sofa on the screen
actually belonged to her house she
freaks out we all know Jade is Cindy's
love interest but this relationship or
better yet an obsession is just
one-sided as soon as Sinjin gets Scott
he leaves with his laptop and tells the
game to not tell his mom it's bizarre
that Sinjin was in Jade's house in the
first place but it's even more bizarre
that he's totally aware she's doing
something wrong and he still does it
this probably seems like a funny joke to
all kids but there's just something
extremely creepy about Sims obsession
with Jade in the same episode received
back to babysitting a dog for a
cheerleader Jade immediately asks why is
Baek doing favors for a cheerleader and
what is that cheerleader doing for him
this probably didn't mean much to you
when you were a kid but we all know what
kind of favors some of the cheerleaders
like to do to the boys they like Tori
versus Sinjin Sinden is definitely one
of those characters that seems to have
way too many inappropriate lines but as
a child you probably never notice some
of the things that came out of his mouth
or other areas for that matter in the
eleventh episode of the series Tori
Poulos engine in a janitor's closet and
asks him to create something so she'll
be able to spy on her friends while
she's explaining the secret plan Sinden
keeps imagining she'll kiss him because
that's what happens in his dream
whenever she pulls him in the janitor's
closet
Tori ignores Syngenta creepy behavior
and keeps on asking him for help until
he agrees when he says yes she gives him
a kiss on the cheek completely shocked
Sinjin watches her leave the closet and
says he's experiencing the same feeling
he already felt before
Tori comes back to tell him she heard
that and leaves again something tells us
that instantons dreams Tori is doing
something more than just kissing him to
make that certain feeling come to Sinjin
the more we talk about sinjen the more
we feel like his stories are all just a
big inappropriate joke sure
teenage boys will do anything to get a
kiss from the girl they like but what
Sinjin is doing is just a bit TMI
slapped with the sausage
if you thought inappropriate jokes ever
end in Victorious you're wrong even
though the show officially ended you can
find more and more adult jokes as Yuri
watch the episodes in the twelfth
episode called cat's new boyfriend
things just get really weird we see the
students partying at the kickback and
the running joke of the night is the
mysterious sausages they are eating
because sicko it's the acting teacher
won't tell them what meat they're made
of that alone should raise a few
eyebrows but it even gets otter we see
Tori watching cat and Danny dancing
Jaden asks her if Danny ever spun her
like that instead of replying
Tori aggressively asks if Jade would
like to be slapped by a sausage any
normal reaction would be saying no but
for some strange reason Jay says yes
Tori obviously refuses but why on earth
would Jade even say yes in the first
place is Nickelodeon implying that date
is familiar with this sort of thing
let's just stop right here before things
get any more gross shall we we can
probably get an idea why Jade would say
yes to getting a mysterious sausage in
her face it's far too inappropriate to
even discuss or telling you Nickelodeon
didn't hold back when it came to adult
jokes on this show you don't know what
I've got the characters on this show
already have big
Nattie's but things can get pretty
bizarre when they get involved with
other things like dummies for example we
all know Robbie has a dummy but do you
remember the scene from the second
episode where we learned far too many
things about his puppet Rex in this
particular scene Tori flirts with Robbie
Robbie has a massive crush on her
anyways but he's too shy to do anything
about it
he escapes tori by giving the excuse
that rex has to use the bathroom pretty
clever right
well Tori doesn't let him off the hook
that easily if you think about it a
dummy doesn't really have to use the
bathroom so it's clear Robbie's just
avoiding her after Rex claims that he
has to be taken to the bathroom because
he has to pee now Tory gets visibly
frustrated as she watches them leave
she then shouts that he's a puppet and
he can't even pee and Rex well it's
actually Robbie if you think about it
replies that she doesn't even know what
he is considering they're talking about
a bathroom ordeal it's safe to say Rex
is talking about body parts implying he
definitely has something you can use to
go to the bathroom it's even odder when
do you realize all of this is being said
by Robbie who manages to be totally
inappropriate despite having a crush on
Tori just the girls teenage boys are
highly inappropriate and we totally
understand why if you've been around
boys while in school you know the jokes
can sometimes go just a little bit too
far but it seems like boys and TV shows
like victorious take their creepiness
and obsession with girls to a new level
that shouldn't even exist Nickelodeon
gave a sad impression from the very
first victorious episode we ever saw in
the first episode Tori's getting ready
for her performance she has to change
and she needs help everyone seems to go
behind the scenes to help her change and
we mean absolutely everyone the guys
only seem to stop when it's pointed out
that it's just the girls that should
help her change her clothes seems
understandable right well it's not
according to Nickelodeon well this is
clearly a funny joke in a comical break
from the showcase nervousness it really
portrays teenage boys in the most
stereotypical way ever
why else would teenage boys want to go
behind the scenes to help Tori change
her clothes if you think about it the
whole situation is kind of gross and
we're just glad they were told that they
are definitely not allowed to go back
there did you catch this joke the first
time around leave us a comment and tell
us what you thought
Puka fish everyone wants soft feet right
the nickelodeon took it a little bit too
far with the soft feet fascinate
in the 12th episode of the first season
we told you this episode is just weird
the episode called cats new boyfriend as
way too many inappropriate scenes and we
bet there are even more of them out
there have you ever noticed how this
whole episode is just about a foot
fetish would you ever really touch
someone's foot at a party it seems to
have been the storyline for this episode
between a used puka fish to make her
feet smooth these fish are known to eat
dead skin and leave you with the softest
beat ever this didn't seem to work on
anyone else because trina actually
bought those fish from a dodgy guy in a
van but have you noticed that even the
doctor even though he was angry about it
still admired Trina's soft feet
not to mention Jay - Trina if the fish
are actually painful and when Trina said
no Jade was visibly disappointed Jade
seems to have a thing for the pain and
when you combine that with her being
okay with getting slapped by a sausage
it just gets a bit weird seriously how
many innuendos are you able to find in a
single of Victorious episode and we made
it to the end of the 10 funniest adult
jokes in victorious you might have
missed for more videos like this one
check out 10 funniest adult jokes in
Jesse you might have missed see you next
time
[Music]